[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW: Hey, everybody.
Welcome back to The Boring Show.
MATT: Hi, everyone.
I am not Filip.
ANDREW: So I'm Andrew.
Again, this is Matt this time.
So we're changing up the
cast a little bit here.
If you haven't seen
The Boring Show before,
this is about an hour long
show, where two Flutter
engineers just work
on an app, covering
some interesting things, make
mistakes, look things up,
and occasionally
interact with comments
that you guys leave on
our previous episodes
and via Twitter.
So we're going to have
some of that as well.
MATT: So that's great.
So I get to make mistakes.
ANDREW: Yes.
MATT: OK, perfect.
Well, we'll see plenty of that.
Good.
ANDREW: Yeah, excellent.
So when last we left our app,
which is a Hacker News reader,
we had just gotten built_value
into the application.
And we had basically
gotten an article object
that was being generated
correctly with source gen
and built_value.
But it only had one
property, which was ID.
And if we look at
the Hacker News
API, which is what we want to
deserialize with this object,
there's a lot more
than ID in there.
So we have all these
fields that we're
going to need to be able to
automatically pull in from JSON
and populate one of these
article objects with.
So the first thing
I'm going to do here
is try and finish up
the built_value portion
that we started
last time by adding
the rest of these fields.
MATT: Cool, so we're going
to build value for this.
ANDREW: Yes.
MATT: OK, that's--
ANDREW: Unless we run
into a snag, in which case
we can backtrack and use JSON
serializable or something else.
MATT: We'll do it by hand.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: OK.
ANDREW: It's only one
little object, so who knows.
So I'm going to go and grab
all of these properties
through the magic of
cutting and pasting.
And this is our old article.
This is going to break many
things, because we already
had that out.
We had made a
second file for it,
so I need to get all those extra
properties into this article
class, so that when
built value runs,
it'll do all of the
serialization stuff for it.
So let me go ahead
and paste here.
And this is going to
take me just a second.
Have you used built_value
yet in anything?
MATT: I've used built_value
a couple of times.
built_value is great for when
your incoming JSON roughly
matches the structure of
your class pretty well.
ANDREW: Yeah, that's true.
If you need to sort of
massage stuff, sure.
MATT: You talk
about built_values,
immutability stuff last week.
ANDREW: We touched on it.
I think that'll-- we haven't
done an app state management
episode yet, which is
something we do need to get to.
We saw that in the comments.
People are curious about it.
And so, I think that'll
be more of an issue
once we get into
that, because people
have very strong opinions about
whether your app model should
be immutable, you know, and
whether you're creating a new--
that's how redux works, right?
Your app state doesn't change.
The actual object
doesn't change.
MATT: That's true.
But by default,
with built_value,
all the values that you
create through built_value
are going to be
immutable by default.
So every time you want
to permutate on an object
or you want to change
the values internally,
what it actually
will do is it will
generate a new one for you.
One of the benefits
of built_value
is that if you build
multiple objects
with the same internal
state, it will not
generate multiple objects
like when you reference one.
And it will give you--
ANDREW: Interesting.
MATT: --things like object
equality and whatnot
pretty much out of the box.
So there's a bunch
of useful attributes
of using built_value
you get just
above and beyond the additional
serialization piece too.
ANDREW: Which is good, because
if you just want serialization,
JSON serializable
does a pretty--
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: --crackerjack job at it.
MATT: Yeah, for small things
built_value might be overkill.
But if you've got a
large app, and you're
going to be generating a ton
of objects, some of which
may be represented
to be the same,
then built_value might
get you some neat service.
ANDREW: Good.
I'm kind of guessing
on some of these types.
I've got to be honest.
MATT: There's a lot of--
that's a lot of parameters.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
Well, you know these
are your fields.
Everything's an item, so
it has to be able to--
oh, time to use a
built collection.
MATT: We're going to have to do
some additional work for built
collection.
ANDREW: [LAUGHS] So this would
be a built list, integers,
which I need to go up here.
And I think we touched a
little bit about this last time
as well.
built_value is for
single objects.
It does have a related package
called built collection, which
I hope we have in our package.
Yeah, we do.
So that's already
been imported using--
that's not how you spell that.
So we've already got that
if I pull up the pub spec.
I think we pulled that in.
Yeah, so we already we're
pulling that one in last time.
Let me just make this bigger,
so that normal human beings
can read it.
So we've already got
that package imported.
Right now, I'm just
adding it to this file
and importing it here.
So arrays, of course,
are by nature immutable.
So if you just have
a getter for a list,
you could still
conceivably mutate the list
unless you have an
immutable list object.
MATT: True.
And built lists are
immutable list objects--
ANDREW: Right.
MATT: --I believe.
ANDREW: And so, that, I
believe, also needs to be a get.
All right.
MATT: So many getters.
ANDREW: I know.
MATT: Nice thing is is
built_value will just create
the constructors for you.
ANDREW: It's really
driving home the point
of me not wanting to write that
deserialization method myself.
Parts?
What the heck is parts?
A list of related poll
options in display order.
I'm going to go
ahead and call that.
A built list of IDs basically.
I hope that's the case.
The fun part is since you'll be
coding the live network calls,
I get to do all this.
And then if it's wrong, it'll
blow up when you try to use it
and I'm sitting over
there, which will be great.
MATT: I'm really glad I
joined in in this episode.
ANDREW: [LAUGHS] And--
MATT: When's Phil coming back?
ANDREW: Yeah, he's coming back.
He's hiding in the
back somewhere.
Descendants is an
integer, I think.
Yeah.
This kind of bums me out.
They have all these
examples of the field,
but they don't have one that's
every single field, you know?
Like, there's descendents--
OK, that's an int.
MATT: Well, worst
case scenario, we can
leave a couple of these out.
ANDREW: Yeah.
Lord knows we've never made
a mistake during an episode
of The Boring Show.
MATT: Well, that's
what I was told.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: Sorry.
You know, I meant
I watched them all.
ANDREW: [LAUGHS] OK, so
those are all my fields.
I should be able to save this
and get an error for something.
Oh, because I just
broke the part file.
MATT: Yeah, you're going
to have to regenerate that.
ANDREW: So let me
go, and where am I?
Let's do-- can I do
this from memory?
MATT: Huh.
ANDREW: I think that's it.
MATT: Isn't it pub
run builder build?
ANDREW: Ah.
I don't get why
they build, dang it.
It is a build task, isn't it?
I was so ready to
flex after that.
No.
MATT: I think the other
one might be build.
There you go.
One of these
permutations will work--
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: --at some point.
ANDREW: There we go.
MATT: There you go.
ANDREW: Assuming
this actually works.
MATT: Yeah, that's true.
ANDREW: So now we're
regenerating that part file.
MATT: Mm-hmm.
ANDREW: This is the
generated source
to match the properties that
you just saw me drop in.
That's the magic of built_value.
Let's go back here, and I've got
all kinds of little properties
in here.
And I bet you if I
scroll down, there's
my constructor, all kinds
of stuff in here, equality.
I would love to know how this
hash code function works.
[LAUGHS] There's the to string.
Cool.
So built_value has just
updated some stuff for me.
So let's try running
one of these as a test
and see how that works.
Let me go ahead--
I have this running.
Let me go ahead and stop it.
And I'm going to pop
out to Hacker News
and just try and grab
one of these random--
MATT: Oh.
You've got your serializers
put into your built_value?
ANDREW: It should be.
Well, that's a good point.
Do I need a serializers file?
MATT: Yes.
ANDREW: OK.
MATT: And you--
ANDREW: Let's go
look at the example.
MATT: Mm-hmm.
There is a really good
series of articles in Medium
on built_value and serializing.
ANDREW: Is perhaps this
what you referring to?
This is the one that David--
MATT: Which-- yup,
they're the ones.
I highly recommend you read
all of those multiple times,
because I did in order to
understand built_value.
ANDREW: Yeah, and you can get
to them right from the GitHub
repo, I believe.
MATT: Oh, they
linked them through.
ANDREW: I believe he
actually links them right in.
I want to-- oh, no.
They're on the pub.
They're in his pub entry then.
So you can definitely
find-- oh, no, articles.
There they are.
Yeah, totally worth
reading if you're
going to do any kind
of serious passing
data on the wire with JSON.
MATT: The other thing that
I found super helpful here
is just that the built_value
has the examples folder.
And if you check out both
serializers and values,
there's a bunch of
very simple examples.
Well, ranging from
simple to mind blowing,
but that's what got me started
when I was first playing around
with built_value.
ANDREW: All right, I'm going
to drop another file in here
that I'm going to call
serializers, which I can never
spell on the first try.
And I'll add that later.
So I'm going to drop in.
This is his example, which I'm
about to trim the heck down,
because I don't
have these classes.
MATT: Yeah, you're just
going to need the one, right?
ANDREW: Yeah.
And this will be coming out of--
what is it?
JSON parse?
We're going to have
to restructure some
of this code in a bit as well.
There we go.
I'll be closing that.
Let me save that.
And I also need the JSON plugin.
Here, we were talking
about this the other day.
MATT: Yeah.
So one of the things
that happens when you use
the out-of-the-box serializer is
that it's going to serialize it
in a weird list-like format
where each tuple in the list
or each two pieces are going
to be a name and a value.
So it's not going to
really look like JSON.
Fortunately, there's a JSON
plugin, which basically makes
it format nicely, where you have
the JSON name-value structure
by default. And so,
highly recommended
unless you're doing some very
bespoke managing of your data
to use the JSON plugin.
ANDREW: Yeah.
The format that they
use by default, it does
have advantages.
Like, you can not have--
put some type
information on the wire,
I think, in a way that--
you know, normally,
if you're doing
JSON, you sort of
have to have agreement
of what things look
like completely on both ends.
And that's how it works.
All right, what did I
just copy out here again?
There we go.
MATT: Oh, you need
to plug-- you need
to add the plugin to your
serializer creator, I think.
ANDREW: Oh my goodness.
OK, file serializers.to_builder.
MATT: Yeah, I think it's the
.add_plugin that you can latch
on to your builder.
ANDREW: There we go.
That's what I'm looking for.
MATT: There you go.
That should do it.
ANDREW: OK.
And so, that's--
OK, so I've got
another part file here.
The serializers file
has its own part file
just like the article one did.
So let's go back
to the terminal.
I don't have to guess
for this anymore
since it's the most
recent command.
It's very easy to write.
There we go.
So this should generate
that part file for us--
MATT: And there will now be--
ANDREW: --if I
come back in here.
MATT: --much
generated source code.
Wow.
ANDREW: There we go.
MATT: Very little
generated source code.
ANDREW: Yeah, that's very small.
And I'm guessing I need
to pull this package.
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: Sorry.
There we go.
MATT: That's the one.
ANDREW: All my little
red lines went away.
MATT: There you go.
ANDREW: That's awesome.
MATT: Oh, look,
you're using new.
How very Dart man of you.
ANDREW: [LAUGHS] There you go.
It's my own fault for
cutting and pasting
code that's more
than two months old.
OK, so let's pop back here.
And I've got that, so
I've got the serializers.
I'm not using dark
convert just now.
I do need to include the
file that I just made.
MATT: Mm-hmm.
ANDREW: And I'm trying
to get it to where
I can use this in
a test just to make
sure it works,
because that's what we
were doing in our last episode.
So let's go back
to parse article.
MATT: So there's a lot
that's involved here
in terms of creating
serializers and part files
and everything else.
But ultimately, when you
look at the amount of code
that you're writing for what
you're going to get out of it,
I'm assuming this is going
to be worth it, right?
ANDREW: OK, abstract
class article.
I'd have forgotten how to
deserialize with built_value.
One second.
MATT: There was a
serializer.deserialize.
ANDREW: That's it.
And you give it the right--
MATT: [INAUDIBLE] serializer
ANDREW: That's it so I should
have serializers.deserialize
with--
MATT: Yup.
ANDREW: --article.serializer.
And I just realized I'm missing
a line from my article class
that I should not be.
So one of the things
I need to do is--
MATT: You need to
pop a serializer--
ANDREW: Yeah, this.
MATT: Yeah, there you go.
ANDREW: So each class reports
that type of serializer
to use to deserialize
it with built_value.
And so, I need to add.
And David Morgan
once reviewed my code
and told me to
put it at the top.
MATT: Oh.
ANDREW: So I have it
on good authority.
MATT: So the creator
of built_value--
ANDREW: Told me where
to put certain--
MATT: Your serializer.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: How rude.
ANDREW: There we go.
And why don't I find you or you?
Is this capitalized?
No.
MATT: Do they have
to be generated?
ANDREW: Oh, I may need
to generate it again.
You're right.
MATT: Yeah.
This is the thing
with built_value.
You get a lot of red lines
until you run the generator.
ANDREW: That's why it can be
a good idea to run the launch.
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: Which I'm not doing
here just because I want
to show each time it's running.
But I think we covered
that last time.
You could run it
with a parameter
to get it to just
watch the file system
and then kick off a rebuild.
MATT: Just be careful--
ANDREW: Oh.
MATT: --your hot rebuild--
ANDREW: We messed up.
MATT: --when that-- oh,
w hat happened there?
ANDREW: Yup, declare.
OK, so this is
the-- see, it just
gave me the right
statement to use.
Such nice people.
It's, like, hey, you're
parsing your code,
and we noticed it sucked.
[LAUGHS] Let's try that again.
Oh.
MATT: There we go.
ANDREW: Ah, I love
mature libraries.
OK, that still needs a
parentheses on the end,
I think.
And I'm missing something here.
MATT: You need to import
the serializer class.
ANDREW: Yeah, that's
what I'm wondering.
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: It must be a--
there we go.
Cool.
MATT: Sweet.
ANDREW: One step at a time.
OK, now I think I can
do serializer here.
I'm going to give it the
object to be serialized,
which, in this case,
would be the parsed JSON.
MATT: Mm-hmm.
ANDREW: So just like before, we
were parsing the JSON into a--
it comes out as a dynamic, but
it would either be a list under
the hood of IDs-- that was one
of the examples we were doing--
or it would be a map
of key-value pairs.
And that internal
format of the map
is the same thing that
build-value will take.
I'm not giving it
the raw string.
And hopefully, this
will work, I think.
[INAUDIBLE] Why
aren't you working--
MATT: Oh, you got built list.
Yeah, that's probably going
to confuse matters slightly.
ANDREW: Do I need--
doing something wrong.
MATT: Let me see if I
can find something out.
ANDREW: Let me put-- maybe I--
if I import built
collection up here?
MATT: There we go.
ANDREW: I think that will get
picked up in the part file.
Cool, OK.
So I was just
missing that import
for built collection,
which was confusing
the poor little serializer,
because, of course,
it has to deserialize
a built collection.
So let's go ahead
and run this test now
that I think I've got all
the statically grabbable
errors here.
There we go.
Is that going to break?
There we are.
Do a reformat.
Let's run-- can I
run you as a test?
Oh, this isn't my
test file, is it?
That's why I can't run it.
MATT: Oh, you've got your--
ANDREW: That's my JSON file.
MATT: Oh, that's a
neat way of doing it.
ANDREW: OK.
OK.
MATT: So you have
that in a test.
You've got your JSON string.
And then you're just
calling the parser.
ANDREW: Yup, and this was--
I'm trying to remember
if this is the real one
or if this is the hacked up one
we were working with earlier.
Let's wing it.
MATT: Let's just cut and paste
it up into a multi-line string.
Might make it easier to read.
ANDREW: [INAUDIBLE] Oh,
deserialization error, OK.
MATT: Yeah, it's not happy.
ANDREW: Internal
link to hash map.
OK, and I'm going to
stop this and back out.
I'm also going to
make this bigger.
Let me go make--
let me go get a--
MATT: I can't remember
with built_value.
Are all of those
parameters required?
Or do you mark them
as required or--
ANDREW: Oh, that's a good point.
MATT: Some of them
might not be there.
ANDREW: I think technically
all of these are nullable.
Let me go back then and start
putting some nullable on these.
And that, of course,
has its own--
is that kind of meta?
Where do you get them?
MATT: Let me see.
ANDREW: And it can't
come out of Flutter.
It's got to come out of Dart.
MATT: Is it part
of meta package?
ANDREW: Annotations.
Can we go steal from
the example again?
Meta, so it is pulling in meta.
MATT: It still
doesn't like that.
ANDREW: Because it's lowercase.
There we go.
MATT: Perfect.
ANDREW: I think that'll do it.
Let me go real quick,
do source gen again
to make sure this is working.
So the built list will
be nullable by default,
because it's a collection.
MATT: Mm-hmm.
ANDREW: But the primitives do
need to actually update, OK.
OK, let me go back, start
closing some things.
And actually, type
should always be there.
By, I think, should
always be there as well.
Time.
I don't think poll
options get scores.
Descendants can be null, OK.
Let's try this.
MATT: I can see now why you
want to do the watch file.
ANDREW: I do like knowing
that it's running.
I made a little button for it
in Intellij to actually do that.
MATT: Oh, that's cool.
ANDREW: OK, let's go
back down to JSON test,
and let's run this one.
It'll probably still fail.
MATT: Oh, ye of little faith.
ANDREW: All right.
MATT: Internal
linked-- what is it?
ANDREW: Internal linked hashmap.
MATT: Do you have the
hash map inside your JSON,
or do you have a map?
ANDREW: I shouldn't
have any of this, but--
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: Well,
let's break it out.
Dynamic.
Oh, I'm not parsing
the JSON string.
MATT: You're parsing a
regular string, aren't you?
ANDREW: I'm just
throwing a string at it.
MATT: You forgot the JSON--
yeah, you should be
encoding your JSON.
ANDREW: Point for me, all right.
I have to write--
MATT: You could've
discovered this 45 minutes--
ANDREW: I know.
MATT: --later.
That would've been riveting
watching on YouTube.
ANDREW: Just got done
talking about how you
need to parse the string first.
OK, so dynamic--
[LAUGHS]
MATT: Yeah, that's--
ANDREW: --equals--
so we've got--
are we doing it in here?
Is that where-- oh wait,
we are decoding it in here.
MATT: Partial article?
ANDREW: OK, hold on.
A week between filmings and
I forget my entire life.
OK.
OK, got a break point in there.
Let's rerun this
with debug on and see
where I've gone horribly awry.
MATT: You know, one of the
other things we could do
is comment out a
bunch of those fields
and just make sure it's
working on a few of them,
because it'll ignore the rest
of them in the JSON object.
ANDREW: OK, there we go.
So let's step over that.
So what is actually
in this data?
Just a little bit
of [INAUDIBLE]..
MATT: Now it's going to--
it's a map of a whole bunch
of strings to other things.
ANDREW: So by is
a string, right?
MATT: Kits is a group of a list.
ANDREW: Which it should be.
That's one of my collections.
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: Descendants is an int.
All right, there's ID as an int.
Where's descendants?
Yeah, descendants is an int.
Score is an int.
Time is an int, which I assume
can hold a value that big.
MATT: Mm-hmm.
ANDREW: Title is a string.
Type is also a string, even
though it should really
be an enum, but that's
something to fix later.
And nullable is a--
and a nullable
string for the URL.
MATT: I'm wondering if it's the
built collection, whether we
have to do something funky
to make sure that that works.
ANDREW: Oh, I'm using
the wrong serializer.
That is the standard
list-based serializer, I think.
And this one is the
one with the plugin.
MATT: Oh, you're calling
the wrong serializer.
You're trying to serialize--
ANDREW: Using the normal format.
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: OK.
MATT: So rule of thumb is
don't have two serializers
in your serializer--
ANDREW: Which I will
fix in two shakes
as soon as I verify this works.
All right, stop, save.
Let us rerun our tests, OK?
MATT: I like the way that
you have deliberately
made all of these
new mistakes with
built list just to
show everybody what--
ANDREW: It's a kindness, yeah.
Just like how I
deliberately don't
prepare for these episodes just
to show everybody everything,
you know?
That's kind of my method.
All right, let's
step over that one.
Can we step over this one?
We can.
MATT: Did that work?
ANDREW: I think it worked.
We got a built
list, information--
MATT: Oh, you've
got a built list.
ANDREW: My key promoter, which
is normally a handy plugin
that I've been running.
OK, so let's take a second,
see what we've got here.
So we now have an
article class that
is implementing built_values
interfaces correctly.
We have a source
gen'd version of it.
Look at that.
Nullable was in
there the whole time.
It wasn't even in a package.
So we have an immutable
article object now
that we can populate from
parse to JSON that we
can get from the network.
And so, I think--
do you want to take a
break here and swap?
And then you can
kind of take this.
And we're going to
tear out some things.
There were some mocks
that got us to--
MATT: OK.
ANDREW: That's not
even running anymore.
The version of this that we had
going from the first episode,
there were some mocks involved.
And so, those would
need to be ripped out,
and this real article
put it in there.
MATT: But you don't have any--
you have no networking
code yet, right?
ANDREW: No networking
code at all.
MATT: So do we want
to build some tests
around the networking code?
I know they're not really tests
that you would want to run,
because they require a network.
But at least they
would get us going.
Or do we want to
dive straight in
and jump straight into
the networking side?
ANDREW: That's a good question.
I think it would be good to
just show at least one call--
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: --to go get some JSON.
And we could still do
that in a test, too.
MATT: Yes, why don't we start
with a test that actually pulls
the JSON back from Hacker News?
And then we can see
it populating here.
And at least then we
know things are working.
ANDREW: Yes.
MATT: Is it going to
return a single article
or multiple articles?
ANDREW: So that's
the fun of the API.
It returns a list of IDs.
So this will be kind of fun.
It returns a list of IDs
that you can get the top--
MATT: Oh.
ANDREW: --500.
And then you need to,
one after another--
MATT: Wait, I have
to make individual--
ANDREW: --by ID.
MATT: --network call by ID?
ANDREW: Individual
network calls.
MATT: Seriously?
ANDREW: Yeah.
We'll probably be talking
about local storage
and caching in our next episode.
MATT: Yeah.
We'll be talking about
not flooding the network.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: OK, well, that
makes life easier.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
OK, so--
MATT: We're not going to do a
built value for a list of ints?
ANDREW: No, no, I don't think--
MATT: No, that would be nuts.
ANDREW: That would just
be a built collection--
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: --anyway.
MATT: That would be overkill.
But for something with
a dozen parameters,
including internal lists of
maps and everything else,
built_value, once you remember
to call the right serializer,
is the way to go.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: OK, so we're
going to switch places.
[SNAPS FINGERS] This
is where we switch.
MATT: All right,
that's where we switch.
See, if Filip was here, that
would've been super smooth.
But Filip isn't here.
ANDREW: You really didn't
watch the second episode
all the way through, did you?
[LAUGHS] I think I
almost kicked over--
MATT: I was coding
while I was watching it.
At least, you know--
ANDREW: All right, you're busy.
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: All right.
And we're back.
MATT: Ha-ha.
ANDREW: Can you hand me that
sheet of paper down there?
The one with writing on it?
Because I want to
talk about some stuff.
MATT: Is there a cheat sheet?
ANDREW: There is a cheat sheet.
MATT: Oh OK, good.
ANDREW: Much like we crib code
from other people's examples.
There we go.
Yeah, so I thought this
also be a good time--
we talked in our last
episode about how
we're going to respond to
questions that people posted,
which is great if I can keep
myself from answering them
too quickly in the
YouTube comments,
which is-- it's my instinct.
I see somebody ask a question.
It's, like, oh, I
can help with that.
And I'll type out an answer, and
it makes it slightly less fun
to answer them here, a
little bit less dramatic.
MATT: We're going
to be dramatic?
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: Excellent.
ANDREW: But there are some--
I actually learned something
from one of the comments
that somebody put down.
And hopefully, the
graphics people
can put it right about
here in a second.
We talked about why there
is no reflection in Flutter.
MATT: There is no reflection.
There is reflection in
Dart, but not in Flutter.
ANDREW: And I kind of butchered
the explanation for why.
And the-- it does
relate to the fact
that the Dart is, ahead of
time, compiled to native code.
But the detail
that I left out is
that Dart takes advantage
of trees shaking.
So it can use--
MATT: Oh.
ANDREW: --you know,
delightful static language.
It's strongly typed,
statically dispatched, I think.
And so, we can go
through and see
which methods you're
actually going
to use out of your codebase.
So if you pull in a
package, you know, you only
use two methods out of
it, it can go in there
and just toss out all the
code that you're never
going to call, which is great
until you try to use reflection
to dynamically call one
of those methods that's
now no longer in your app.
So that is the reason
that reflection is out
for the moment.
There is talk about bringing
in some annotation-based stuff
to tag things and say hey, I
might call this with reflection
later.
Don't take it out when
you do the tree shaking.
But as of right
now, no reflection.
So thanks for that comment.
I actually, you know, got to dig
in and learn something from it.
What else did we have?
We also had something--
I don't think this is
going to come up today,
but somebody mentioned
HTTP overrides in Dart.
Have you ever used those?
MATT: I have never used
HTTP overrides in Dart.
ANDREW: It's a way to short
circuit the HTTP client library
and say, run this
code as if this
object I'm going to give
you is the HTTP client.
MATT: It's like marking
out the HTTP piece?
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: So you can just
provide JSON directly
from, I don't know, shared
preferences or something?
ANDREW: Whatever you
want to do, mm-hmm.
MATT: Oh, that's cool.
ANDREW: So for
testing, you know,
it's how you would build a
little convenient fake HTTP
client.
MATT: Is that with the Dart
HTTP or the HTTP package?
ANDREW: That's a good-- we
could probably look it up
real quick if you want want.
MATT: We should
probably look it up.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: Where's your--
oh, there we go.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: Dart HTTP override.
ANDREW: There you go.
MATT: It looks--
ANDREW: I think if you
look in HTTP client,
you'll see it on the left.
So if you-- or am I
used to the Flutter one,
where we get all
the rest of them?
Not on there?
MATT: Not that I could see, no.
ANDREW: OK, it does exist.
It's not like the
Snuffleupagus, I swear.
It's definitely in there.
Cool, OK.
So--
MATT: Right.
ANDREW: Let's get
back to some things.
MATT: Great, IntelliJ.
I use Visual Studio Code, so--
ANDREW: Yeah, I know.
MATT: --this is going to be fun.
ANDREW: Filip uses
Android Studio.
MATT: So we're going to have
some interesting coding, OK.
So how does this work?
We have this, and you have
your tests in json_test.dart.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: So conceivably, I can
create a new test, right?
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: That is going to do
something like parses item.json
over a network.
And so, right, what
are we going to do?
We're going to not want
to have this anymore.
So we can--
ANDREW: Yeah, we're going
to go get the real business.
MATT: And we are going to have--
so you use const.
I typically use things
like final for mine,
which I prefer much less.
If I'm going to
have a URL in here--
ANDREW: I think
Filip wrote that one.
[LAUGHS]
MATT: OK, all right.
We're going to use final.
ANDREW: Actually,
real quick, I ran
into an interesting discussion
with some of the tools team
when we were talking to them
this past week about how
constants-- if you
change a constant,
they said that will get
reloaded for a hot reload,
but a final will not.
MATT: Oh, it'll
rebuild the constants?
ANDREW: Because that's--
so it's a stateful--
MATT: Oh.
ANDREW: --hot
reload, so it wants
to keep track of the
state of your object.
And so, that includes
any final variables
that you've set at that point.
But constants aren't
considered part of that state.
And so, apparently, if you
set a const on a variable,
hot reload will update that.
If you're setting
const somewhere,
and you want to see
the effect of them,
it will update that
for a hot reload.
But a final, it'll be
like, oh, that's app state.
I'm stateful, so I'm not--
MATT: Interesting.
ANDREW: --going
to overwrite that.
MATT: I'm going to
have to try that out.
ANDREW: Probably doesn't
matter for a test,
but it's an interesting bit
of trivia that I came across,
and I wanted to share it, too.
MATT: OK, so where's my
Hacker News API docs?
ANDREW: That would be--
we had them just a second ago.
I think maybe you overwrote
them with that one.
MATT: Hacker News--
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: --API.
There we go.
ANDREW: I think this it's
just an open endpoint.
MATT: OK, so let's have a
look and see how this works.
So we have--
OK, so there's a prefix.
So let's just get that in.
SO URL prefix.
And I'm not going
to be super clever
and build these with
nice URL builders.
I'm just going to go
straight for the string
and be done with it
for the beginning.
So you said that there
is a way of getting IDs.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm, so it's--
MATT: Where is this?
Is it this?
ANDREW: Down a little bit more.
No, top.
There it is.
MATT: Top stories, OK.
So we are going to start
by getting top stories.
No, we're going to get best
stories, because they're
better than the top stories,
because they're the best.
All right.
ANDREW: I don't know if best
is best all time or what.
MATT: Bestest--
ANDREW: I think--
MATT: --stories ever.
ANDREW: --there might be a
.json on the end of that.
I don't know.
MATT: You know what we can do?
We can--
ANDREW: Now, we can always test.
MATT: Nice URLs.
I cannot create a new tab.
I can cut and paste
like a normal person.
Oh.
ANDREW: [LAUGHS]
MATT: I have broken Firebase.
ANDREW: No.
MATT: OK, let's
try it with .json.
ANDREW: There we go.
MATT: I think this is-- because
this is using the Firebase--
ANDREW: API.
MATT: --standard database.
OK, there we go.
ANDREW: There we go.
MATT: OK.
I didn't break
Firebase, awesome.
So we need
besteststoriesever.json, chase
and that's great.
OK, so what are we
going to do next?
So we're going to
have call HTTP.
So Dart has a
built-in HTTP library.
ANDREW: Mm-hm.
MATT: It's fine.
It's really good.
But people have
improved on it and have
created a HTTP
package, which, if we
go take a look at the
Dart pub packages,
we shall see that usually
it's up near the top.
ANDREW: Yeah, one would imagine.
MATT: It's probably one of the
D package you will almost always
include in, which gives
you really nice things
like basically giving you
gets and posts really,
really, really easily and
returning things as a future
as HTTP does.
This also is super useful
if you want to stream data
into your apps.
So if you actually want
to get a stream of bytes
and do some funky real-time
parsing as the stream of bytes
comes in, this also
can support that.
I'm not going to get
into that, because I
don't remember how it works.
But trust me, it
is there somewhere.
So we're going to do
a couple of things.
One is, I think, weirdly--
even though it's not
in our pub spec--
ANDREW: Are you thinking
it might be on--
MATT: --it does--
ANDREW: What just happened?
MATT: --actually
exist, because--
ANDREW: Does something
else depend on it?
MATT: Flutter does.
So it's in there with Flutter--
ANDREW: Interesting.
MATT: --which is nice.
Don't depend on
versions that are--
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: --in Flutter, because
as much as version dependency,
et cetera--
ANDREW: Yeah, as much fun
as implicit unversioned
dependencies we
should probably have--
MATT: I pretty much
remember that these
are very low numbers.
But trust me, this is
not super alpha software.
This is actually-- this is
actually used by everyone,
and most of those people
run the Dart team.
You'll recognize
those email addresses.
ANDREW: Oh yeah, there's Kevin.
MATT: Yeah, and--
ANDREW: He's found
errors in my code before.
He's a nice guy.
MATT: Your code's perfect.
ANDREW: [LAUGHS] Because
it's been reviewed.
MATT: Save.
And does this automatically--
ANDREW: No, you've got
to do a packages get.
MATT: Use get?
OK.
Visual Studio Code does--
No ID was here.
That's fine.
[INAUDIBLE] things.
ANDREW: Did you do the get?
MATT: There we go.
ANDREW: That also works.
MATT: Yay, OK.
ANDREW: When in doubt,
the command line tools
are always there.
MATT: Yes.
So we have our URL.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: And we are now
going to fetch our things.
So I think we can
just do http.get.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: This is going to take
our URL out This is nice.
This is going to
return us a future.
So I could do final
response equals a weight.
That's fine.
And then I can make this--
ANDREW: Do we have to
tag that as a async--
MATT: Async, which is probably
a better way of doing it.
Actually, with HTTP, using
.then leads to nice structures.
But because we're going to
do an expect at the end,
it's going to lead to--
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: --anonymous
function madness,
so let's do it this way.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: So I'm just going to use
my res there, which is fine.
So what do we have?
OK, so probably I want to check
if res.statusCode is usually
do not equal to 200.
Then we're going to do
some error checking.
You know what?
This is just us doing a test.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: So I'm just going to
keep this nice and simple
and not handle any errors.
And so, what's this
going to give us.
This is going to
give us res.body.
This is JSON.
ANDREW: It should be just--
do we have to decode that
or anything like that?
MATT: We're going to
have to encode it,
because this is a string.
I don't think it--
ANDREW: We don't get
UTF-8 for free, right?
Is there something
we have to do to go
from a byte stream to
an actual string or--
MATT: I think this
will give us UTF-8.
ANDREW: Oh, wow.
MATT: In a stream situation,
you have to decode the bytes.
ANDREW: OK.
MATT: When you get the body, I--
we're going to find
out in a second.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: So we're going to say
this is res.body so-- in final.
JSON string equals res.body.
And that's going
to be json.encode--
ANDREW: Wait, I think
parse article's doing that.
If we go back and
look at it, I think
this is where I ran into
trouble half an hour ago.
Command, click
will do it for you.
MATT: Am I doing
something wrong?
ANDREW: No.
MATT: Oh, it's because my
code base is all broken.
ANDREW: OK.
Yay.
MATT: OK, perfect.
ANDREW: So I think it's
doing the decode, yeah.
MATT: It's just a random string.
ANDREW: I just ran into
an issue last time.
MATT: OK, let's-- we
don't need to do that,
so we just need to do res.body.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: OK, so how do I run this--
ANDREW: Wait a second.
MATT: Oh, wait.
Look at that.
ANDREW: [LAUGHS]
So we'd forgotten
that we're getting the
best stories list and not
the articles.
You're parsing an
article with a--
MATT: OK.
ANDREW: --list of items.
MATT: So my-- yes, we
now have a list of IDs.
So we're going to do some
manual JSON deconstruction.
ANDREW: There we go.
MATT: So we are
going to do final--
we're going to ID
list JSON equals--
my naming is terrible.
json.decode.
And we are going to
decode my res.body.
ANDREW: I may have pulled
dart:convert out of the imports
above.
MATT: Beg your pardon?
ANDREW: I may have--
I don't think I have
dart:convert in this file.
MATT: OK.
ANDREW: [INAUDIBLE]
MATT: Import dart:convert
gives me my JSON.
OK, so at this
point, json.decode,
it's going to give us a dynamic.
But it's going to be an
iterable, because it's a list,
I think.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: So we should be fine.
I could do something a
little more clever like this.
Not too sure if we
need to do that here.
ANDREW: So that would get
you a list of dynamic, right?
MATT: I think that would convert
that dynamic into a list.
But it would be--
ANDREW: But then it
would be a generic type
that would be list--
MATT: Of dynamic.
ANDREW: --of dynamic, OK.
MATT: So let's not do
anything too clever, because--
ANDREW: Works for me.
MATT: I know what happens
when we do clever things.
Don't work.
And so, we're going to
do ID list JSON dot--
we're probably-- you know, let's
just see if this is working.
So let's do if--
this is no longer JSON.
It's just ID list.
ID list.length is--
no, because we have
lots of things like isnotempty.
ANDREW: Oh yeah, there's
isempty and isnotempty.
MATT: Yeah, it's really handy.
Then what we can do is we can--
oh, we're going have to
do a second network call.
Oh, this is going to
get complicated, OK.
So this is good.
OK, bear with me.
We're going to know have a
final story URL, of course.
Are you a double quotes
or single quotes person?
ANDREW: I'm single
now that I use Dart.
MATT: Yeah.
I used to do a lot of Python.
I'm a single quotes
person myself.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: And this is going to be--
let's take a look at the
network call, which is here.
Oh, OK.
So this should be nice.
We don't need pretty printing.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: We don't need any
of that sort of nonsense.
What we need is vo/item/id.json.
So it's v0/item.
And it's going to
be something.json.
ANDREW: String
interpolation for the win.
MATT: And we're going to really
make this super ugly by doing
idList.first.
Do you like that?
ANDREW: There you go.
MATT: Is my code
super readable now?
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: Yeah.
OK, so what do we have now?
So we have this, so
now we can do final--
what are we going to call this?
We're going to
call this storyRes
equals http.get, storyUrl.
That's lovely.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: Going to have
to do this too.
And then what we're
going to have is we're
going to hopefully have our--
you know, just in case.
This is going to--
ANDREW: Pop up in there.
MATT: --live here.
And then this is
going to be res--
no, no.
It's going to be storyRes.
So that's going to make two
network calls come back.
We're going to expect
this, and we're-- well,
that's probably
going be wrong now.
ANDREW: No, you
can put, you know,
ID is not equal to zero
or something like that.
MATT: Well, we can run
this with breakpoint
and see if it works, right?
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: OK.
ANDREW: Yeah, in the
real world, of course,
you'd want to use
an HTTP override
or some other mechanism
to test everything, but--
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: --the actual networking.
MATT: Yes, do not actually
put your actual networking
in your actual unit tests.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: Well, you can.
ANDREW: Yeah, have a
separate integration test
file or something like that
that you don't mind waiting
45 seconds for it to complete.
And so--
MATT: Sometimes these
tests when you do async,
you can actually--
handy tip-- where is it?
Where's my async?
Is this in need of async?
ANDREW: Yup.
MATT: Yes.
You have additional-- how do
I show the parameters of this?
ANDREW: Oh, Command-P.
MATT: Command-P. Command-P.
ANDREW: If you're-- you're
outside the method now.
So if you went back to in
between the brace and the--
MATT: There?
ANDREW: Yeah, I
think that'll work.
Try again.
MATT: Ah, there is a timeout,
and that is very handy when
you're doing, you know, not
networking, but if you're--
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: --listening
for streams or you're
doing whatnot,
that will save you
some madness if things
accidentally run
in an infinite loop or whatnot.
So timeouts are handy when
you're doing async stuff.
Handy tip, which I
learned the hard way.
Right, how do I run this?
ANDREW: So we would want
to go from main.dart here.
We want to pull that down and
go back to the test files.
MATT: So I got my break point.
Got my main.dart--
ANDREW: No, sorry.
Up here, where you're pulling
down the wrong configuration.
So go to parses item.json.
MATT: You added this
as your configuration?
ANDREW: I think Filip
did a while back.
MATT: We're blaming
Filip for everything.
ANDREW: We-- yeah, he
gets a lot done, you know?
MATT: He does.
ANDREW: And then you can go here
and click that and do debug.
There we go.
MATT: All right,
let's see what--
oh.
Oh, Flutter instance
already running.
ANDREW: Yeah, well stop it
and kill it, I guess, yeah.
MATT: There we go.
Are you dead?
ANDREW: [INAUDIBLE]
MATT: I will do that again.
So we go here, we go debug.
Now we're running
a Flutter instance.
Hang on a second.
Hang on.
Maybe I hit stop.
Oh, I'm going to try that again.
Yay.
ANDREW: There we go.
MATT: My terrible
IntelliJ skills.
IntelliJ is awesome.
It's been too long
since I used it.
ANDREW: Oh, oh.
Things are happening.
So we--
MATT: Oh, so we've got--
OK, so if we look here, we've
got res-- we got ID list.
Oh, look at that.
So ID list is working--
ANDREW: Lots of IDs.
MATT: --we've got lots
of IDs, much IDs, so IDs.
Our story URL is pulling
out the first one.
Awesome.
We have storyRes.
And where our--
we get our bytes--
ANDREW: That's our bytes, which
I don't want to look at and--
you could step into this.
MATT: Oh, yes.
ANDREW: So that would be--
MATT: This one?
ANDREW: That one.
MATT: Story-- oh,
where am I now?
Oh, wow.
ANDREW: Yeah, it did that.
MATT: [INAUDIBLE] that one.
Did I get somewhere new?
ANDREW: You're back
where you were.
MATT: Oh.
ANDREW: You can try stepping in
again, and maybe that'll be--
there we go.
Now, you can do step
over, which is just
to the left of where you were.
MATT: This one?
ANDREW: Yeah, one
of these days I'll
memorize these key commands.
MATT: Well, you have.
I'm the one who's asking.
ANDREW: Yeah, I memorize
what the buttons look like.
That's about--
MATT: Oh, check it--
ANDREW: --as elite.
MATT: And got to
step down again.
So what do we have now?
ANDREW: So parse a string.
MATT: But check out our--
reduce the string.
We've got kids, we've
got descendants.
ANDREW: So it hasn't actually
made the article yet.
That'll be the next call.
MATT: Oh, look at that.
Why nobody ever wins
the car at the mall.
ANDREW: Oh, I read
that this morning.
MATT: That's the
bestest story ever.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
It's-- no one wins the car.
It's true.
It's a good article.
MATT: That's actually--
that was almost
if we'd planned to
pull that article out.
It could've been something
entirely inappropriate.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: But we got lucky.
OK, so I can just--
ANDREW: Wait, one
more step over.
We've got to make the article.
MATT: One more step over?
ANDREW: All right,
article parts.
MATT: Oh, genius.
ANDREW: Boom.
MATT: Look at that.
It's like-- so in the
space of-- let's have
a look, a few lines
of code, most of them
me, you know, checking to see if
things are pulled down, right?
Making a call in Dart,
in Flutter, is like that.
The nice, thing, though, is--
I mean, coming obviously
from Android development
and whatnot, where
you have to wrap
these things in an
async task and run them
in a separate thread or
whatnot, because Dart
is asynchronous by
default, you can just
do http.get, await or
[INAUDIBLE] and pull it down.
JSON decoding for
simple structures,
we had a list of ints
that work quite nicely.
We I didn't didn't even have
to cast that to anything else.
It knew that it was in a
dribble, and it pulled it out.
And they were ints.
Actually, well, it doesn't know
if it's an int or a string,
because I just used it here.
And then we pulled
the story URL.
And through the magic of--
where's your article parser?
ANDREW: It's in
JSON parsing, which
is what lets you
know it really needs
to be moved somewhere else.
MATT: Yeah.
No, where is your-- is this it?
Yeah.
And through basically the
magic of built_value--
we did have to do some
boilerplate to define it.
But there is no JSON
parsing in sight
here, because it
was over-generated.
And so, once you get past the
defining this and defining
your serializer, which
was literally this,
things were good.
So we have your article
objects, or class.
We have your parsing
handling really nicely.
And we now have a network.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: I mean, Filip would have
got this done in 10 minutes.
We've been at this for a while.
ANDREW: Yeah.
Actually, let's ask our
off-camera producer.
How long have we
been filming now?
SPEAKER 3: 42 minutes.
ANDREW: 42 minutes?
OK, so we've got some time.
Do you want to switch
back real quick?
MATT: Yup, let's--
ANDREW: OK.
MATT: --do magic 3D cut
thing and switch back.
ANDREW: Here.
MATT: Oh, could
fall off the chair.
ANDREW: I know.
They go up so high.
It's like wearing a bustle
in the 19th century.
MATT: Do you have
experience for that?
ANDREW: No.
MATT: OK.
ANDREW: It's what I imagine
it-- you never imagine
what a bustle would be like?
SPEAKER 3: One
second [INAUDIBLE]..
ANDREW: That's fine.
All right.
There we go.
And we're back.
MATT: Oops.
ANDREW: [LAUGHS]
MATT: Now we're back.
ANDREW: Yeah, so let me--
so one thing I
wanted to mention,
and this is a bit of
shameless self-promotion
here, the Flutter
team, we put together
a new repo for some samples.
MATT: Oh.
ANDREW: And it's not
accepted right now,
because they don't have push
or writing requests yet.
I got to talk to Ian about it,
but I do have a pull request.
We have a JSON example
that has gone through.
It's actually what David
Morgan and Kevin Moore--
MATT: Oh, that's using--
ANDREW: --reviewed.
MATT: --their JSON
serializer builder plugin.
Not plugin, package.
ANDREW: It's deserializing
the same set of strings using
three different approaches.
So a roll-your-own
dart:convert approach,
a JSON-serializable approach.
That's a library for
JSON serialization.
And then also built_value.
MATT: Oh, cool.
ANDREW: And so, that will be in
the Flutter/samples GitHub repo
hopefully by the time
this episode makes it
into post-production
and gets released.
MATT: How do you
have nine stars when
there's nothing in the repo?
ANDREW: People like me.
MATT: OK, true.
ANDREW: I'm naturally charming.
MATT: Just--
ANDREW: And-- no.
[LAUGHS]
MATT: Your code is so
awesome that it's--
ANDREW: No, I think--
MATT: In anticipation
they're starring your repo.
ANDREW: No--
MATT: I like that.
That's good.
ANDREW: -- I don't think people
even knew it was my repo,
because it's--
I mean, it's really not.
It belongs to Flutter
team, who made it.
And, you know, I'm sure
people saw it and were
like, OK, they'll eventually
put something in there.
And we will be putting
things in there.
So, this will be one of
the examples that goes in.
And the idea is that you can
look at three different ways
to serialize JSON and see
which one is right for you.
So I wanted to mention that.
And also, I think-- because
we're a little over 40 minutes
or so at this point, and to
keep going right now, what
do we need to do?
So we've got a model.
MATT: Mm-hmm, so
we've got the model.
We've got the back
end pulling it down.
So how hard would it be to wire
in the rather naive networking
code that I've written and get
that displaying an article in--
ANDREW: In an actual app.
MATT: --the Flutter app.
ANDREW: So let's
go look at the--
MATT: I mean, we could just say
for any article you click on,
it shows the article that
gets pulled over the network.
But--
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
So we've got-- let's see.
MATT: Look at all these news.
ANDREW: Yeah, I know.
MATT: It's the new police.
ANDREW: Yeah, because
the very first episode,
I think we recorded way
before it was released.
Not the case anymore.
We now have a lead
time of about a week.
So yeah, let's get
rid of all these news,
actually, all of that,
through the magic of--
does VS Code do this?
Just out of curiosity.
MATT: It might do--
ANDREW: I assume it does.
MATT: --but my VS Code-fu
is clearly not as strong
as your IntelliJ-fu, so--
ANDREW: Let's see if
I've actually broken it--
MATT: --I would
doff my hat to you
if I wasn't wearing a beanie.
ANDREW: All right, let's
go back to main.dart.
Let's get out of
testing right now.
So this is the UI layer
that Filip worked up
in the very first episode.
Let me make this a little
bit more readable here.
Hide this.
MATT: Nice.
ANDREW: A little bit
too big in that area.
Yeah, so we have a basic app.
And he is pulling things
out of this, which is just
a hard-coded list of articles.
So--
MATT: But where is it showing--
is there an article page?
ANDREW: There is
build item, which
is going-- it's using a
list builder, I think?
Yeah, a list view.
And the children
are a map of-- he's
just mapping the list of
articles to a list of widgets,
basically.
And it's [INAUDIBLE]--
MATT: So in an ideal world,
what we probably want to do
is we want to pull the articles.
We want to cache them
somehow, so we're not
hammering the network.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: And then that--
ANDREW: That gets into a
heavyweight article about app
state management, though.
MATT: Yeah, maybe not now.
Maybe we could just pull
the article, and just--
we could generate a list from
it and show the same article
multiple times.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
MATT: Or when we get down to
showing the article itself,
we could just
override the article
with a piece of networking-fu
to inject the new article.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm, so let's--
OK.
So we're definitely not going
to want that anymore, articles.
So let me-- I'm going to--
MATT: You're probably
going to want
to have two functions, one which
is get ID list and get article.
So we can break
those out of the test
and pop them into
the utils function
or whatnot, whatever-- whichever
way you want to structure it.
ANDREW: Yeah, OK, I'm going
to pull all this code out
and put it into article.
And that will be our new model.
So I've commented out--
for those of you who've
been with us through
all three episodes,
I'm commenting out
the original one.
And then I'm going to
call this article.g.dart.
And--
MATT: You're going to have to do
your serializer magic as well.
ANDREW: I'm going to
comment that one out
and this one, because
we're not going
to be using that one anymore.
So I will need to--
I guess serializers needs
to move, doesn't it?
Let's put that up here.
MATT: And you'll probably need
to-- do you need to import
the--
yeah.
ANDREW: There we go.
MATT: Nice.
ANDREW: So we're just
doing a little shuffle now,
and I just broke main.
[LAUGHTER]
Because comments count
never existed really
in the first place.
That was a made-up
field that we made.
And we'll comment
this out as well.
Write an IOU to this
whole section of code.
And also, our tests are
broken, so that's fun.
Let's comment those out as well.
MATT: Common practice
when your tests break--
ANDREW: Comment them out.
MATT: --comment them out.
ANDREW: Yeah, that works.
And then I think we can rerun
built, rerun source gen,
and we'll get article.g.dart.
MATT: Yeah, and--
ANDREW: So we'll get
the same article class.
MATT: Your serializer will
rebuild to point to the right.
ANDREW: Or it
could just blow up.
That's also a possibility.
MATT: I'm sure it'll be perfect.
ANDREW: Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
MATT: That's a new warning.
ANDREW: I see that
Dart UI warning a lot.
I think that's come
up in other episodes.
MATT: Yeah, I think
that's because it's
a holdover from
what they're doing
on the web side of things.
But you can ignore that one.
It has no bearing on what
it produces ultimately.
ANDREW: Yeah.
Although, if you are a Dart
coder for the web, built-value
works just fine.
MATT: Yup.
ANDREW: It works on both.
MATT: This is one of those
works across all platforms.
So--
ANDREW: OK, so now
we've got an article
that's is serializable, right?
So we could now
go back into main
and say let's use that somehow.
So we could--
MATT: OK.
ANDREW: What if I just--
what if I faked a list
of IDs, say 10 IDs,
and I just put them
in an array up here,
and then we set up
something that would--
MATT: Well, why don't you--
didn't we--
ANDREW: --can
fetch them somehow.
MATT: Can you go back
into your console panel,
because you could just steal all
the IDs from that if it has--
ANDREW: Oh, I was actually
going to go back to your call.
MATT: Oh, we could just get
it from the other web call.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: That would
have been simple.
I think it's the next one over.
ANDREW: OK.
No-- oh, there we go.
MATT: There you go.
ANDREW: So let me just
steal some of these.
That looks like about 10, right?
And we'll go back.
And I'm just going
to drop these.
Let's change this to
an int for right now.
MATT: Mm-hmm.
ANDREW: We'll call it IDs.
MATT: Nice.
ANDREW: Let me get rid of that.
And this is going to--
MATT: Auto-format.
ANDREW: Junk.
MATT: Dart format is great.
ANDREW: So now I got some IDs.
It would be--
MATT: Oh, you're going to do
some clever mapping things,
aren't you?
ANDREW: I'm going to--
I'm wondering if I can map the
IDs to future builders that
will kick off the request
and then parse the result.
MATT: So we're going
to create a function
to do the HTTP networking stuff
and return a future article.
ANDREW: Mm-hmm.
I'm also going to pull out the
refresh indicator for right
now.
Forgive me, Filip.
There it goes, OK.
MATT: Wait, I can hear--
ANDREW: Yes.
MATT: --the sounds
of screaming--
ANDREW: Somewhere 12,000--
MATT: --in the distance.
ANDREW: --miles away.
Filip-- OK.
OK, so now I've got that.
I've got one too many
of those, I think.
There we go.
So now I want to map the IDs.
This is going to be some
serious functional programming
here, probably more than
I can really handle.
MATT: Oh, this is going to
return a list of futures.
But that's kind of OK, I think.
I think you can
probably handle this.
ANDREW: Let's just make
sure I'm doing this right.
Always good to have the
right of our parentheses, OK.
MATT: So that should
work now and just--
ANDREW: Yeah, this
is going to produce
a bunch of ugly text widgets--
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: --I think.
So let's go ahead and through
the magic of hot reload,
there they are.
MATT: Oh, look at
that, it's still--
it's running this whole time.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: I didn't actually
kill it when I hit stop, OK.
So the problem here is just
that we're going to map this,
but it's going to map to a--
it's going to map to
a bunch of futures.
There is a way of saying
don't return the map
iterable until all the
futures are futured up.
I just wish I could
remember how to do it.
ANDREW: Well, I was
wondering if we could do it
with FutureBuilder, because with
FutureBuilder, we could just
make the request to give it the
future that comes off of that.
MATT: Well, if we passed the--
so if we-- yeah, we
could do, actually.
So if we-- oh.
This is it.
This is hardcore.
ANDREW: We're going
to do a widget, right?
MATT: So FutureBuilder is
going to return a widget.
You're going to have to give
it a future, oh, and a builder.
ANDREW: This would be a
widget builder, which is what?
Just build context?
MATT: It'd be build context.
And it would be async
task of type widget.
ANDREW: Let's just look at
FutureBuilder real quick.
Again, one of the best parts
about Flutter, all open source.
You can always go
look at the docs.
[LAUGHS]
MATT: Yeah.
Although-- yup.
ANDREW: So it takes a future,
an initial data, and a builder.
And the builder is--
MATT: Builder--
ANDREW: --async widget builder--
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: --typed, which is
build context and a snapshot.
MATT: Of a certain type.
ANDREW: OK, this is getting
slightly more complicated
than I hoped it would be.
But let's see what I can do.
MATT: No way, we're good.
ANDREW: All right,
so this would be--
MATT: This would be--
ANDREW: --this build context.
MATT: --build context.
ANDREW: And then a
MATT: Async snapshot.
ANDREW: --article.
Async snapshot of
an article, right?
MATT: An async-- well, you're
returning ultimately a widget,
right?
ANDREW: Let's just
say null for now.
Why are you yelling at me?
What have I forgotten?
MATT: Because you've got
Widget in FutureBuilder.
It has to be the same type.
ANDREW: Oh, of course.
There we go.
And that's going to
be a big function.
So let me just go ahead and
make it what we're at now.
So we are-- and then we
need a future, right?
MATT: Yeah, we need a future.
ANDREW: Future is--
MATT: You know, we
could just do HTTP--
oh no.
ANDREW: Because we need
to parse some stuff.
MATT: Because we'll need
to parse some stuff,
so we might want to have--
why don't we have a function--
why don't we create a function
that returns a future, and then
just pop the--
ANDREW: So it would take an ID--
MATT: [INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW: --it would return
to a future article.
Does that makes sense?
MATT: Yup.
ANDREW: So future
article, get article.
And that will take an ID.
And so I would-- let
me go look at the test
that we just wrote to do this.
There we go.
MATT: So you only need the--
you don't need the first half.
You only need the bit with
the pulls from the ID.
ANDREW: Right there.
MATT: There you go.
ANDREW: Cool.
I'm going to go back
into main, boop.
OK.
MATT: Well, it's all good.
You have to make--
ANDREW: And that
becomes ID, which
means we don't need the
brackets, which is fun, right?
MATT: Yeah.
And you'll need to
make that async.
ANDREW: Async.
MATT: And--
ANDREW: And we need
to import HTTP.
MATT: Mm-hmm.
And then it's usually
HTTP as HTTP--
ANDREW: That's right.
MATT: --so you don't
have weird GET--
ANDREW: Instead of polluting--
MATT: --methods
all over the place.
ANDREW: It's the
global get method.
MATT: That's good.
ANDREW: It's fine.
A story URL if a story--
oh.
I think that was wrong
on the original test.
MATT: Oh, it's like you
said my code was wrong.
ANDREW: Still worked.
storyRed is definitely not this
little Freudian slip there.
OK.
MATT: And you want to
return the parsed article.
OK.
ANDREW: That seems
suspiciously easy, OK.
So that would be getArticle
for i, like that.
MATT: Mm-hmm.
ANDREW: And so, here
we might have data.
We might not, right?
MATT: So this is
basically-- the builder
has to return the widget tree.
ANDREW: OK.
MATT: So you probably want
to return build item article.
ANDREW: Let's just two texts
for right now until we get--
know that we're--
MATT: I believe in your code.
ANDREW: Yeah.
OK, let's just do that.
ANDREW: I don't.
But we've got to check to see
if the snapshot has data, right?
MATT: Yes.
ANDREW: OK.
MATT: So one of the things when
you're using FutureBuilder is--
ANDREW: I'm going to change
that to snapshot, by the way.
MATT: FutureBuilder has a--
snapshot has connection.
Oh, that's an interesting
way of doing it.
ANDREW: Oh, is
this not how you--
MATT: I do it differently.
ANDREW: How do you
do it, actually?
MATT: So if you do if
snapshot.connectionState--
ANDREW: connectionState.
MATT: --equals equals
ConnectionState--
ANDREW: Some enum value.
MATT: Yeah, dot done.
There's a whole bunch
of them in there,
but done means the
future is finished.
ANDREW: Interesting.
MATT: And then
for anything else,
I usually then just show a
circle progress indicator
to show that you're waiting.
And by the magic
of Flutter, it just
will show the circle
progress indicator
until the future's
complete, and then boom.
ANDREW: And then the
future updates, OK.
MATT: You don't like
circle progress indicator?
ANDREW: I like text.
It's like the console debugging
of the Flutter widget land.
MATT: Alert.
Let's just use alerts.
ANDREW: [LAUGHS]
Alert [INAUDIBLE]..
MATT: If there's
not an alert widget,
I'm going to write an
alert widget just for you.
ANDREW: You should have seen
me when I was doing C++ stuff,
I would be-- like 20 printf's
was my debugging method,
because it's all--
MATT: Join us as we reminisce--
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: --down memory lane and
how we use print statements
to debug our code.
ANDREW: Join us next
week on code done badly--
MATT: Flutter--
ANDREW: --in the past.
MATT: --the advanced way of
writing mobile apps via text.
ANDREW: [LAUGHS] All
right, Text, article, dot--
MATT: Name?
Title?
ANDREW: Oh, wait
snapshot article--
MATT: Oh yes, it's going to
be snapshot.data, dot title?
Name?
It should pick up the type.
ANDREW: Oh, oh.
MATT: Oh, there you go.
ANDREW: That's right.
MATT: There you go.
ANDREW: Let's do title.
and I should probably
put returns on this.
MATT: Yes.
ANDREW: Because it's good to
have functions return things
when they have return types.
I almost don't want to do this.
MATT: I-- yeah, I'm curious.
[GASPS] Did that just work?
ANDREW: Holy crap.
MATT: Oh no-- oh, there we go.
That did work.
I hope they're all OK.
ANDREW: Let me pull
up padding on here.
Now that it works, let's
add a little padding, yeah.
MATT: Can you put in my circle
progress indicator now, please?
ANDREW: OK, so it's a widget.
Again, it's something
I've never used.
So circle--
MATT: Circular.
ANDREW: Circular.
MATT: ProgressIndicator.
ANDREW: You'll find
my IQ is normal.
MATT: And that's it.
ANDREW: Oh, just like that?
MATT: And let's see.
Watch.
Oh.
Now, the problem there is
that because we're doing it
inside the map, it's going to do
one for each, which, you know,
we can fix, but you'll
probably need to center
that, because
otherwise it's going
to take up the full thing.
That's why they all look weird.
ANDREW: OK.
MATT: So if you wrap
that in a circle--
ANDREW: Wrap with widget.
MATT: Center, I beg your pardon.
ANDREW: Oh wait, center
has its own thing.
MATT: Yup.
ANDREW: There we go.
MATT: So let's see if
that does something.
There you go, OK.
ANDREW: I can't
believe that worked.
MATT: Complete faith.
So you--
ANDREW: Now we can
use build item.
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: So OK-- so
what did we have to--
comments.
We still have a comment
count, because that's--
I think we covered this
in another episode.
It's actually hard to calculate.
But we could do type.
MATT: This is a row,
and you're going to--
OK, sure.
And you've got an icon
button for launching the URL.
That's cool.
ANDREW: OK, so we'll
do the article type.
And then, well, we were
doing a fake URL before.
So let me go ahead and
get a real article.
OK, my least favorite
bug currently
in the IntelliJ plugin, which
is fixed in the new release,
by the way.
MATT: Oh.
ANDREW: By the time
this makes YouTube,
that might already be fixed.
There's a weird thing when you
do tab, it replaces too much.
MATT: Might want to be
careful, because you've
got the URL in two places.
You've got fakeUrl
and article.url.
ANDREW: Yeah, I'm going to
get rid of fakeUrl and just--
MATT: Yeah, we don't
like no fake URLs.
ANDREW: There we go.
All right, and then
this would become
build item snapshot.data.
Oh.
[CLAPS]
MATT: Data not equal to null.
ANDREW: Is that in text?
I often do this.
OK, so texting is getting--
oh, OK.
MATT: That's article.text.
It's article.title?
ANDREW: Title should
be article dot--
oh, because some of
these might not be--
interesting.
OK, so I'll just do this
for now thanks to the magic
of the coalesce operator.
MATT: But isn't it
article.title or article.text?
ANDREW: I think
it's [INAUDIBLE],,
so I could check our--
MATT: Oh, we had
text, which is--
ANDREW: Oh, no,
no, you're right.
MATT: --which is the comment or
story, and title is the thing.
So I think they all had titles--
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: --because you were
displaying them earlier.
ANDREW: You're right.
It should be title anyway.
So I'll leave the
null coalesce in there
and just switch that to title.
MATT: And your
key, you might want
to change just in case
your keys get messed up.
ANDREW: Oh yeah, I'm
sure that's not--
MATT: That's a thing,
what happens with lists.
ANDREW: Yeah.
Oh.
MATT: Oh, is that going to work?
Is that going to click through?
And are we going to
be able to read why
nobody buys things in the mall?
ANDREW: Is it loading?
MATT: I think it's loading.
It's loading something.
ANDREW: Did we use some
weird proxy setting on it?
Some weird proxy
on the simulator?
MATT: Can you build
things from the emulator?
ANDREW: I should be able to.
MATT: Well, try another one.
ANDREW: I mean, I'm
loading things from this.
MATT: It might just
be-- might be the--
might be the site URL.
That's The Guardian.
Surely, The Guardian works.
ANDREW: There we go.
MATT: Yay.
ANDREW: And less plastic trash.
That's nice.
MATT: Your app's done.
ANDREW: Holy crap.
MATT: You're finished.
ANDREW: Yeah, we're done.
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: End of series.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: Thanks for joining.
ANDREW: All right.
MATT: Hey, Filip,
we're really sorry--
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: --but you missed
the end of the show.
ANDREW: We solved it all.
MATT: Yeah.
ANDREW: All right.
This seems like a natural
stopping point then
for this episode.
MATT: I think we're going to--
we've chanced our luck enough.
ANDREW: Yeah, so
things to reiterate, do
please post comments and
questions on the video.
You can also do
#BoringShow on Twitter.
There are a few from
there that we saw as well
and tried to answer.
And we will be back.
I think I might not be
in the next episode.
Maybe it'll be
you and Filip or--
MATT: One of us.
ANDREW: --you and whoever
we can drag down in here
into the studio or something.
MATT: So one of
us doesn't exist.
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: Yeah.
At any point, one
of us doesn't exist.
ANDREW: Never see
the same one again.
That's nice.
MATT: So there will
be a surprise lineup--
ANDREW: Yeah.
MATT: --in the next show.
ANDREW: And yeah,
give us some ideas
about how you would like
state management done,
if you have a particular
approach to it
that you'd like to.
MATT: Oh, wait.
I have to turn up for
the state management one?
ANDREW: Yeah, it's all you.
MATT: Oh, great.
ANDREW: You gave the talk at IO.
You'll be fine.
Because there's a
bunch of options,
and it seems like we don't have
to do that in the next video,
but we might want
to touch on it now
that we've gotten some of
these basics figured out.
So--
MATT: We're getting close.
ANDREW: You know, blocks,
redux scoped model,
It might be good to just roll
our own inherited widget just
to see it.
MATT: Yeah, or even just
set state in places, but--
ANDREW: Yeah, or just, you
know, stateful widgets.
They work pretty good.
MATT: Mm-hmm.
ANDREW: But yeah,
I think that's it.
MATT: Perfect.
ANDREW: Yeah, thanks
for sticking with us.
MATT: See you later.
ANDREW: See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]